[Musique]
vacances j'oublie tout vraiment c'est le
titre de ce dimanche en politique
au coeur des vacances de février
occasion de voir ce qui se passe donc au
coeur de nos entreprises sur le terrain
de la qualité de vie au travail un sujet
important est grave
un chiffre pour mieux comprendre les
enjeux en france trois millions de
salariés seraient victimes ou menacés
par un burn-out vous savez c'est ce
qu'on appelle maintenant une phase
d'épuisement professionnel va parler de
toutes ces questions et de bien d'autres
avec nos invités que je vous présente
autour de cette table christelle monier
de l'aract l'association régionale bfc
bourgogne franche comté donc pour
l'amélioration des conditions de vie au
travail bienvenu merci d'être là
louis droit qui est président de la
confédération des petites et moyennes
entreprises du territoire de belfort
isabelle zèle matt vous avait consigné
dans un petit livre il ya un an
votre parcours professionnel parsemé
d'embûches et nous en parlerons merci à
vous aussi d'être avec nous et enfin
frédéric que mon journal du cabinet
coelho ce qui accompagne les changements
au sein des entreprises y en a beaucoup
en cette période et vous êtes confrontés
donc à ce titre à la souffrance au
travail et aux risques psycho sociaux
vous pouvez bien sûr réagir tout au long
de cette émission en utilisant le
hashtag dean paul bfc bonjour à tous une
première question qui a dérogé à la
règle sacro-sainte du droit à la
déconnexion pour venir aujourd'hui
dimanche dans cette émission pendant ces
vacances tout c'est tout je pense que
oui voilà donc voilà c'est dommage pour
vous c'est vrai que le droit à des
connexions c'est un nouveau concept en
fait qui est apparue il ya quelques mois
seulement
c'est anecdotique ou c'est important de
pouvoir déconnecté quand on est cadre
notamment
on est envahi par les mails par les
portables à la maison dans le cadre
privé il fallait en passer par là pour
s'est pas assis avec de petits que c'est
en fait non je crois que c'est pas si
anecdotique que ça et si la loi a écrit
c'est ce droit à la déconnexion c'est
que c'était quand même un besoin de la
société de prendre en compte cette
question là qu'est ce que la loi prévoit
pas ce qu'on en fait je crois que c'est
quand même beaucoup laissée à la
responsabilité des entreprises bien sûr
ces lycées à la négociation dans les
entreprises mais elle prévoit un droit à
la déconnexion et après chacun doit
négocier au sein des entreprises ce que
ça veut dire que le droit à la
déconnexion
en fait tout le monde va pouvoir un
moment donné se couper de son travail
c'est pas évident aujourd'hui puisque
les outils bas sont souvent des fils à
la patte un smartphone et hôtes vous
avez parlé des mails on peut facilement
les consulter pendant ses vacances ou le
soir ou le week-end c'est pas si facile
non plus selon les personnes selon les
fonctions qu'elle tienne selon leurs
responsabilités et puis selon comment
l'entreprise gère les absences donc
c'était nécessaire de pointe et ça
c'était une demande de toute façon
sociétal des cadres et des non cadres
faux c'est vraiment une évolution
sociétale une attente au travail ou se
78 % des cadres consultent leurs mails
en dehors du temps de travail c'était
votre cas aussi quand vous étiez car
dans l'entreprise mam'zelle matt white a
fait c'était mon cas le droit à la
déconnexion pour moi c'était inexistant
ou est ce qu'on peut dire que c'est
parfois peut être un peu le début
justement des problèmes quand on
n'arrive pas à décrocher complètement
qu'est-ce que vous rencontrez dans les
entreprises que vous visitez madame au
journal tout à fait je pense que c'est
en effet pas du tout anecdotique puisque
ce qui conduit à l'épuisement
professionnel c'est justement cette
incapacité à un moment donné de
décrocher du travail et était tout le
temps en fait l'esprit occupé par ce qui
se passe au travail et pour expérience
on a animé une conférence qu allianz
il n'y a pas très longtemps la semaine
dernière avec des dirigeants
d'entreprises et on leur a demandé de
nous donner leurs téléphones portables
pendant tout le temps de la conférence
est à l'issue ils nous ont remerciés en
fait en effet de leur avoir permis
dépendant attend sans le l'esprit un tir
tiens il faut que je regarde mon
téléphone portable un côté vraiment
invasif des mails de
sphère privée que les chefs d'entreprise
j'imagine connaissent eux aussi de la
même manière avec l'urgence de tous tout
devient urgent maintenant alors est il
possible de faire un état des lieux de
la situation justement dans les
entreprises de ce rapport que les
travailleurs les salariés ont avec
justement leur travail qu'est ce qui
pose le plus problème finalement dans
notre pays aujourd'hui dans l'entreprise
est ce que c'est les rapports avec la
hiérarchie ce que c'est les rapports
entre collègues est ce que c'est le
stress la pression économique qu'est ce
qui pose en était le plus problème alors
ça peut être un peu tout ça ça dépend
vraiment des contextes ce qui pose
problème en est on a on a changé de
contexte économique enfin on est dans
une économie mondialisée on a des
contraintes on a beaucoup de l'imprévu à
gérer d'aléas
le travail s'est densifié on en demande
toujours plus dans des délais souvent
plus court avec d'une qualité supérieure
tout ça fait qu'on a un faisceau de
pression qui augmente sur le travail si
ça c'est pas très bien régulé en interne
c'est à dire s'il n'y a pas un
management qui est capable de gérer des
priorités de dire ce qu'il faut faire
d'abord et puisqu'il faut laisser un peu
de côté si on n'a pas une organisation
de travail efficace avec où on sait qui
fait quoi quand et pourquoi
si on voit pas bien le sens de ce qu'on
fait alors on risque d'aller au delà de
graves problèmes quoi et le burn out
c'est l'étape ultime
quand des salariés ne peuvent plus faire
face à des situations travail on en
parlera tout à fait est-ce que
conjoncturellement les choses ont changé
se sont aggravées peut-être une certaine
façon je ne sais pas depuis 2008 2010 la
crise luda - oui ça n'a pas ça va pas
arranger les choses
il ya une immédiate et de peu dans tout
de plus en plus dans dans les
entreprises qui fait qu'en fait il faut
tout faire très très vite et que
l'évolution du mode de fonctionnement
des entreprises
la disparition gérer des back-offices
très souvent qu avait un cadre pour pour
l'aider on peut expliquer une assistante
quelqu'un qui faisait le travail entre
guillemets secondaire fait que
aujourd'hui il faut il faut il faut il
faut tout faire que tout ça arrive sur
l'ordinateur et le téléphone du du
collaborateur ou du chef d'entreprise et
que c'est toujours pour hier qu'il faut
que ce soit traitée qu'est ce qu'on vous
dit dans les entreprises alors dans les
entreprises on retrouve ce que dit
monsieur de rang en effet où il ya une
précipitation du travail en tout cas ce
qu'on peut percevoir également aussi
c'est que il ya de plus en plus
d'entreprises qui sont sensibles à cette
question de la qualité du travail de la
souffrance au travail et pour revenir à
ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure en
terme de qu'est ce qui va générer en
fait de la souffrance au travail
ce qu'on peut percevoir c'est que quand
la qualité de lia avec la hiérarchie ou
entre collègues est bonne voire
excellente alors la pression du travail
est beaucoup moins importante en tout
cas génère beaucoup moins de situations
de stress c'est d'abord j'aimerais avoir
votre avis là-dessus parce que j'ai
l'impression qu'on colloque beaucoup
effectivement sur toutes ces questions
vous vous savez ce que je veux dire
on en parle beaucoup on a parlé plus en
plus la souffrance et à et j'ai
l'impression que plus on en parle plus
on met des outils en place et adra et
moi on résout le problème parce que
c'est une impression que j'ai ou est
elle totalement fausses non il n'est pas
totalement faux ce n'est pas totalement
vrai non plus pour faire une réponse de
normand
ce qu'on constate en fait en france
aujourd'hui c'est qu'il ya quand même
des entreprises qui ont pris conscience
de ces problèmes là et qui essaye d'agir
donc en gros on a à peu près une
entreprise sur deux qui met en place des
actions d'amélioration de la qualité de
travail et à peu près une entreprise sur
deux au 6 qui traite la prévention des
risques dont les risques psychosociaux
et le snes donc les choses progressent
on n'est pas sans fin sans moi c'est pas
beaucoup une sur deux la baisse est
beaucoup plus c'est des chiffres qui
sont en hausse donc les choses
progressent dans le bon sens
après on peut avoir aussi des choses qui
sont de la vraie qualité du travail des
fauves de la fausse qualité de vie au
travail quand on travaille ces sujets là
il faut s'attaquer au vrai problème est
souvent les points noirs qu'on a encore
ses on a du mal à traiter les questions
d'organisation des questions de données
contenues travail de sens du travail et
on va rester sur des choses un peu
périphériques cosmétiques sur cet
intéressant ce que vous dites pas ce
qu'est ce qu'il y aurait un mal français
de ce point de vue la terre qu'est ce
que dans notre culture notre psychologie
on serait pas particulièrement près en
france a abordé ces questions comme
peuvent le faire peut-être je sais pas
les entreprises scandinaves où la
culture scandinave ou anglo saxon la
qualité de vie au travail c'est pas un
sujet nouveau
et c'est un sujet qui est arrivé dans
les années 70 justement par ces pays là
les pays anglo-saxons où les pays
nordiques
donc ils ont plus l'habitude peut-être
de traiter ces sujets là c'est pas le
même rapport au travail c'est pas la
même culture non plus on peut pas
comparer les pays entre eux en france on
progresse on progresse alors que t'es
trop doucement mais en tout cas c'est un
sujet qui maintenant quand même devient
d'actualité il ya beaucoup d'entreprises
qui essayent de nos poignets quoi oui il
ya le besoin il envie de deux ans de
l'employé parce que c'est pas tenable
c'est pas tenable dans le temps et c'est
le paradoxe entre l'évolution de notre
société qui nous en demande de beaucoup
très vite et avec des marges de
manoeuvre et des marges financières à la
sortie pour l'entreprise de plus en plus
faibles et ceux et ce besoin
d'immédiateté fait que amende est on
arrivé à cette pression qui est
intenable qui en est fait dans le temps
a pas de sens c'est la patience d'autant
plus que quand ça marche mais il ya une
meilleure performance au sein de
l'entreprise
madame au journal vous travaillez
notamment des entreprises américaines
yale en ont fait presque une religion
feu contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait
penser le bien-être au travail
oui c'est pas à proprement parler des
entreprises américaines en tout cas
c'est des entreprises qui sont basés en
france et qui font partie en fait de
groupes de plus important américain est
en effet ce que j'ai entendu de la part
de directeurs de ces entreprises qui
sont basés en franche comté c'est que
aujourd'hui ce qui est plus regardé ce
n'est pas tant le rendement de
l'entreprise parce que parfois ce
rendement d'une entreprise franc
comtoise est très faible par rapport au
rendement du groupe mais que c'est
beaucoup plus le bien-être des salariés
au sein de l'entreprise pour l'image
mais certainement pas comme en tout cas
pour l'image du croate
image mais important un peut-être que
c'est pas que ça
en tout cas aujourd'hui en effet ce qui
est plus regardé c'est le bien-être des
salariés au travail plus que le
rendement qui parfois est très faible
par rapport au rendement du groupe et
que il ya même une injonction en fait
d'un bien-être des salariés puisque
c'est pas le rendement qu'il faut faire
que l'entreprise soit maintenue c'est le
gagne être des salariés
bon en tout cas je rencontre ça depuis
quelque temps dans certaines entreprises
franc-comtoises on est loin encore de ce
standard j'imagine enfin en france c'est
pas c'est pas là c'est pareil là on peut
le regretter parce qu on peut même dire
c'est que pour certains groupes les
outils de mesure du bien-être au travail
deviennent des outils de pilotage de
l'entreprise donc ça c'est vraiment très
nouveau donc a eu tout national de
baromètre de choses comme ça ça de
baromètre tc les résultats en fait
l'intention qu'on porte sur les
résultats qui va devenir un outil de
pilotage de l'entreprise un outil de
pilotage stratégique de l'entreprise
voilà est vraiment ça c'est nouveau
alors quand on parle de souffrance au
travail est évidemment une sorte de
l'étape ultime qui fait peur à tout le
monde déjà le mot fait peur le burn out
qui est en passe pratiquement de devenir
si j'ai bien lu toute la littérature
le nouveau mal du siècle il avait le
matin vous allez vous faire part de
votre votre histoire vous avez couché
sur le papier dans ce petit livre qui
est paru il ya quelques mois maintenant
il ya un an qui s'appelle rebondir
vous étiez responsable de la
comptabilité était adjointe de direction
adjoint de direction vis de médecine du
travail dans un imbécile le métier
travail je peins postes de cadres restés
pendant plus de 25 ans alors qu'est ce
qui se passe à un moment donné alors une
fête ce qu'on appelle un burn-out
oui alors un burn out ça vous arrive pas
comme ça un matin quand on se réveille
il ya des signes avant coureurs ça
s'installe de façon assez insidieuse je
peux vraiment vous en parler je vais
essayer de faire court pour planter le
décor en 2010 en tout cas pour ce qui
concerne l'organisation dé médecine du
travail
elles ont connu des réformes importantes
qui ont changé profondément
l'organisation les axes de gouvernance
pendant cette période là en plus a été
corrélée à des départs des démissions
des nouveaux venus donc comme je gérais
tout ça j'ai tenu un rythme assez
effréné avec des amplitudes horaires
très forte des journées de travail de
10h jusqu'à fin 2014 où j'ai vraiment eu
une alerte très grave une pathologie
assez importante et un matin de juin
2015 comme je décris dans mon livre je
me suis effondrée sur mon lieu de
travail j'ai fait un avc
voilà donc ça c'est une forme très
sévère la base est reconnu comme
consécutif au burn-out fin tout à fait
puisqu'il a été reconnu comme accident
du travail et j'ai moi même entamé une
procédure pas dans le but d'être en
opposition vis-à-vis de l'entreprise
mais pour pour moi il ya un vrai débat
quand je vous entends je suis d'accord
je rejoins ce que vous dites mais moi
j'accompagne aujourd'hui des personnes
qui sont confrontés à cette
problématique puisque je me sens un peu
missionné et leurs discours ce que lé le
disent c'est vraiment très différent de
ce que j'entends aujourd'hui alors c'est
à dire une sorte de dichotomie aux fins
de oui je pense qu'aujourd'hui
malheureusement en france on est dans un
discours d'opposition et pas dans un
discours de collaboration on n'est pas
et c'est ça qui fait que ça bloque
à mon sens à mon humble avis et à ma
modeste position puisque certains
salariés moi me disais c'est des propos
que je sais des verbatim qui m'ont été
transmis oui on a eu une présentation
par un cabinet sur les risques
psychosociaux le médecin du travail je
sais pas trop à quoi il sert
l'entreprise met une croix dans un
formulaire pour se dédouaner de son
obligation légale de son obligation de
sécurité
mais concrètement à l'intérieur après
c'est pas le cas de toutes les
entreprises
il ya vraiment des entreprises qui
jouent le jeu alors on peut être fait
réagir sur ce premier point et après ils
y apprennent de la détection comment on
peut détester au sein de l'entreprise
donc sur ce sur cette critique
finalement que le a écrit vous formulez
en tout cas va vous vous observez c'est
le regard
voilà qu'est ce qu'on peut répondre
quand on arrive à des situations de
burn-out 1 de salariés alors souvent une
à un puis deux puis trois c'est ça veut
dire que pendant des mois et des mois
les problèmes n'ont pas été traités ça
veut dire qu'on a laissé une situation
se dégrader alors pas volontairement
forcément puisque les signaux on les
pas forcément on en fait de plus en plus
petit à petit on voit pas forcément tout
de suite le sens mans ce dimanche ça va
aller mieux etc
et puis ben on ne traite pas les
questions qui se posent au nom d'une
fusion par exemple vous avez parlé d'une
réorganisation qui sont liées à baho
sens du travail à l'organisation à la
partition déroule entre les uns les
autres et puis on traite pas la question
de la charge de travail parce que dans
ces périodes là il ya la charge de
travail qui peut augmenter pour certains
postes
et puis bah ça vient pas du jour au
lendemain effectivement se dire que
c'est ça témoigne d'une dégradation
collective est malheureusement passé des
individus qui parfois en font les frais
quoique et la mort 2 alors à qui la
faute il n'y a pas de coupable
il faut sortir de l'idée du coupable de
la victime c'est un système qui à un
moment donné à 10 missionné alors les
dirigeants n'ont peut-être pas été assez
attentifs les managers ont été pris
aussi d'un système et puis pas se sont
laissés embarquer dans la situation les
salariés ont tenté de faire comme ils
pouvaient dans une situation dégradée
y'a pas il n'y a pas un coupable d un
système qu un moment donné se met à des
esquisses des règle est on est on
n'arrête pas le dérèglement et on arrive
à avoir là-dessus oui oui totalement
d'accord alors ça ne touche pas que les
salariés
le burn out et aussi fait des chefs
d'entreprise à mot quand même avec vous
au louis ii roi puisque vous avez mis en
place dans le territoire de belfort une
sorte d'opération vous appelez
l'opération casques bleus si j'ai bien
compris auditifs 10 parties casque place
ça consiste en quoi
c'est un dispositif d'intervention
d'urgence pour pour le chef d'entreprise
en difficulté psychologique avec un
numéro d'appel 7 jours sur 7 24 heures
sur 24 qui vous lit peuvent nous joindre
au niveau 2 de la ceppm eux on nous
appelle pas pour nous dire je vais me
mettre une balle dans la tête ce soir
c'est heureusement parfois souvent le
cas c'est souvent à l'appel parce qu'il
ya des difficultés dans l'entreprise et
on se rend compte très vite derrière qui
a des problématiques de burn-out aussi
chez le chef d'entreprise parce que
cette pression qui est liée à toutes ces
tensions et sait où on est fille a pas
forcément responsable derrière au départ
le chef d'entreprise lévy aussi donc on
se rend compte aujourd'hui de ce besoin
aussi du dirigeant d'être accompagné
face à un risque un moment de pétage de
plombs psychologique dont la compagne
derrière avec l'appui d'un dispositif
d'accompagnement psychologique est un
suicide de chefs d'entreprise tous les
trois jours en france
oui tout à fait c'est les statistiques
qui peuvent ressortir même si elles sont
aujourd'hui pas complètement mesuré mais
c'est ce qu'on estime aujourd'hui
quelles sont les solutions à tout ça
c'est la question que j'ai envie de vous
poser maintenant l'état de lieu les
faits il est il est très au dessus enfin
il est plutôt obscures oui il ya
vraiment des démarches de progrès
visiblement qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
continuez en parler pour changer
justement essayer de deux bouts de
perturber ce ce cercle vicieux ce
système que vous décriviez tout à
l'heure christelle monier pas dit ça il
faut oui effectivement parler c'est à
dire que souvent ce qui se passe c'est
que les salariés ou les dirigeants qui
sont victimes de ces phénomènes à ce
qu'ils osent ils n'en parlent pas donc
déjà en parler c'est une première chose
ensuite c'est faire un état des lieux
oui mais analyser les causes de ce qui a
produit sa et sortir de la logique
coupable victime et se dire qu'est ce
qui fait qu'on en est arrivé là c'est
pas arriver du jour au lendemain donc ya
eu des événements il ya eu des
dysfonctionnements qui n'ont pas été
traités
il ya eu des choses qui ont mal été fait
en matière d'organisation peut-être
qu'on a laissé filer il ya peut-être des
managers qui n'était pas à l'aise dans
leur poste et puis qui n'ont pas celui
traité des difficultés pour qu'on
cherche les causes et une fois qu'on a
identifié les causes
là on va trouver les bonnes actions il
faut mettre en place des choses alors
voilà d'être un baby foot dans le hall
de l'entreprise
on est d'accord pour que ça suffira pas
je crois que ça suffit parce que c'est
une solution à un vrai problème c'est
qu'il faut pas se tromper de qualité de
vie au travail la qualité de vie de
travail c'est le travail d'abord le
quotidien du travail l'organisation du
travail et le management
les autres buts des caches misères des
subterfuges ça peut être très ça peut
être intéressant pour le confort de
travail mais ça veut dire qu'on a traité
déjà tous les autres semblaient voilà la
corbeille de fruits le baby foot c'est
bien quand on a un bon climat social
quand les choses se passent bien et puis
de l'employeur se dit bah on va
améliorer le confort de chacun dans son
travail le rôle du chef d'entreprise il
est quand même
important c'est à dire que oui bien sûr
c'est lui qui peut donner aussi le tempo
il est d'autant plus important qu'il en
est le responsable en tant que dior en
tant que dirigeants qu de l'entreprise
ce qui est important pour lui c'est
qu'il soit capable en effet d'être en
veille par rapport à tout ça parce que
les causes peuvent venir du management
mais elle peut venir de plein d'autres
choses de l'évolution économique de la
relation clientèle d'une mésentente
d'antan aux salariés de plaintes
dysfonctionnements et je crois que ça
doit être une veille permanente et et un
souci quotidien dans l'entreprise de de
faire attention à ce qu'il y ait
toujours cette huile dans les rouages
qui fait que les moindre couac vont ne
vont pas prendre une ampleur une ampleur
importante et on ya tout intérêt pour le
devenir de son entreprise a tout laissé
là où le rôle du du chef d'entreprise
vraiment primordial parce que c'est
vraiment lui qui va impulser et s'il
n'est pas dans une réelle intention de
faire changer des choses et de d'amener
en fait une amélioration de qualité de
vie au travail
alors on peut pas faire sans lui
vraiment ça se fera pas si a pas cette
volonté du jade entreprises mais amman a
effectivement il est primordial le rôle
du chef d'entreprise mais comme j'ai
entendu récemment son principal souci
aux chefs d'entreprise et je pense pas
vous contredire et c'est de faire de
l'argent c'est cesser de faire tourner
son entreprise pour pouvoir la faire
vivre pour pouvoir continuer à payer ses
salariés et à faire face à ses charges
il a déjà un énorme souci et pour lui
c'est très très lourd ça à gérer
d'où toute l'importance pour moi des
managers de proximité
un chef d'entreprise il peut pas tout
faire tout seul il peut insulter mais
c'est pas à deux c'est pas lui qui peut
le faire enfin à mon sens je ne crois
pas il peut pas le faire seul tout ça
c'est une co-construction qu'était quels
sont les grands principes que la france
alors il ya un plan il ya aussi le 3e
plan santé au travail qui est un qui est
à l'oeuvre actuellement
qu'est-ce qui les dictent ce troisième
plan santé au travail quels sont les
grands principes
parce que en fait
ce sont des questions qui ont été peu
prise en compte jusqu'à maintenant elles
le sont plus en plus alors le plan santé
au travail et donc et national est
décliné dans chaque région identifie des
risques prioritaires à traiter et puis
le troisième là puisqu'on est dans le
troisième qui va se terminer en 2020 a
mis la qualité de vie au travail au
coeur des axes de travail de ce plan
terre que l'état a pris conscience que
c'était un vrai enjeu pour les
entreprises c'est un enjeu de
performance économique et social de
maintien en emploi des salariés et de
performance globale de vade société
française quoi donc la qualité de vie au
travail pointé comme un des axes majeurs
c'est faire un état des lieux outiller
les pme pour qu'elles puissent agir sur
le sujet et qu'elle se trompe pas de
sujet justement un outil biais du chef
d'entreprise aussi pour qu'ils puissent
insuffler ça et puis c'est aussi amener
à un peu plus de négociation d'accords
d'entreprise sur sur ce thème là là
encore on a un il ya des progrès à faire
même si c'est quand même des choses qui
commencent à entrer dans les moeurs mais
qui est qui et qui progresse alors
concrètement est-ce qu'on prenne comme
préconise puisque les paroles et les
open space on a beaucoup parlé en donner
est-ce que c'est des choses qu'on
préconise plus est ce qu'on peut aller
vers plus de télétravail aussi ça c'est
possible
j'ai un chiffre trois français sur dix
auraient recours partiellement au
télétravail actuellement est ce que
c'est une solution quand quand c'est
possible
alors c'est pas une solution miracle
déjà tout le monde ne peut pas faire du
télétravail une aide à domicile vous la
ferez pas télétravail et des métiers qui
de toute façon sont exclues de ça alors
oui ça peut être une solution en tout
cas ça peut être vecteur de qualité de
vie au travail mais il ya des conditions
hier qu'il faut se donner des règles du
jeu il faut veiller à ce que le
télétravailleur ne soit pas isolée ses
terres exclues d'entreprise ce qu'on
peut recréer d'autre part créer d'autres
problèmes
on peut créer vous parliez de
déconnexion tout à l'heure on peut créer
de l'hyper connexion des gens qui sont
chez eux et qu'ils n'arrivent pas à
faire la part des choses entre privé le
professionnel et qui travaille tout le
temps donc le télétravail ça peut être
une solution mais ça s'accompagne ça
s'anticipe et notamment sur les aspects
techniques sur les aspects
organisationnels management
et puis des règles du jeu ces deux trois
jours par semaine mais pas plus
attention parce que sinon il ya d'autres
risques c'est très bien vécu un pour les
faits les français qui le met en place
quand on les questionne 80% sont très
satisfaits ils sont très satisfaits
parce que ça a été anticipée il puisque
les choses sont posées si une
organisation pas et c'est pas idéal
reproductible non c'est pas reproductive
à l'identique il faut y réfléchir en
interne comme vous
co construire et concertée entre les
salariés coincés ça je pense que le plus
important c'est que l'entreprise
construisent les solutions qui vont être
bonnes pour elle et pour ses salariés et
qui est pas quelque chose qui soit
plaqué qu'elle soit construisent en
interne les soumissions alors il est
aussi un terrain presque de l'utopie sur
ces questions là on est loin du baby
foot dans le lot d'entreprises on parle
maintenant de l'entreprise libéré qui
serait quoi une version moderne de ce
qu'on appelait l'autogestion est ce que
c'est la panacée est ce que ces
nouvelles cette nouvelle génération
d'entreprises qui surgit alors c'est pas
la tenue si là encore c'est une
philosophie entreprenariale on va dire
je n'en trouve libéré on sait quoi là
alors c'est ici un modèle
organisationnel qui se développe depuis
plusieurs années en france et puis dans
les pays européens
l'idée c'est de dire on va accorder au
salarié une grande liberté en matière de
décisions sur leur travail et de
responsabilités et d'autonomie
ça veut dire des hiérarchiser
l'entreprise donc limiter le nombre de
niveaux hiérarchiques
et puis confier les responsabilités à
ceux qui sont censés être expert de leur
travail donc ceux qui le font alors ça
nécessite aussi quand même des principes
d'abord il faut une condition très très
forte du dirigeant il faut qu'ils
acceptent de partager pouvoir quelque
part de partager les décisions il faut
que derrière les gens sont accomplis
sont accompagnés ont dit pas le vendredi
soir je ferme mon entreprise et lundi on
passe une entreprise libéré c'est pas ça
marchera pas là c'est voué à l'échec
d'office
il faut que les managers soient partants
il faut aussi se donner des garanties en
terme de deux petits qui prend quelle
décision quel est mon rôle dans le
processus de décision ce n'est pas
l'anarchie c'est pas la liberté de faire
ce qu'on veut c'est la liberté de faire
ce qu'on doit c'est pas tout à fait
pareil tout et il ya des exemples dans
nos régions bourgogne franche comté
entre les libérer on and on a animé un
groupe de travail l'année dernière nous
il y avait une quinzaine d'entreprises
bourguignonnes franc comtoise qui avait
mis en place ce dispositif là et qui
témoignait à la fois de leur réussite de
leurs difficultés quand ça marche bien
les chiffres les résultats économiques
s'en ressentent et puis les indicateurs
sociaux aussi c'est à dire que c'est ça
peut marcher très bien mais là encore
c'est pas un modèle à plaquer d'une
entreprise à une autre
c'est une condition entre c'est une
conviction très forte du dirigeant izany
no sur le curseur du dir
là sur la formation que j'ai fait dans
le cadre de ma reconversion d'une école
de coaching
ça me fait penser ce que vous dites à la
théorie de mcgregor
c'est à dire c'est le dirigeant le
manager le leader il doit savoir
naviguer entre le xla y c'est à dire
contrôler donné effectivement désordre
et à la fois responsabiliser les
personnes avec qui ils travaillent leur
permettent d'être autonome avoir
confiance en eux le dirigeant que vous
que vous avez décrit c'est ça en fait
c'est quelque chose qu'on pourrait
l'imaginer dirigeants ressources donneur
d'ordres est aussi porteur de sens alors
vraiment ce que vous disiez sait que sa
compagne parce que ça peut générer de la
souffrance au travail
six salariés se retrouvent avec une zone
de responsabilité plus importante est
qu'il est pas prêt et qui ça fait peur
donc il ya vraiment tout un
accompagnement pour aller vers la
libération de l'entreprise donc ya pas
de fatalité à cette situation qu'on a
décrit au début que même temps pas
forcément au top niveau il ya des
raisons
et d'espérer il marche très bien je
précise que vous organisez au niveau de
l'aract et de l'association nationale
une semaine de la qualité de vie au
travail qu'il est en juin et je pense
qu'il ya toute une série de colloques ou
deux animations du 17 au 21 juin c'est
chaque région organisent des
manifestations dont bientôt les
programmes seront en ligne vous pourrez
aller voir ça et puis prochainement
aussi on a une matinale avec l'apec sur
la qualité de vie au travail donc les 5
mars à besançon
donc on essaye de promouvoir un peu ses
démarches et puis de d'aider les chefs
d'entreprise et les drh à aller vers un
type de démarche
est ce que vous êtes heureux et heureuse
au travail vous-mêmes les uns les autres
ça va être question personnelle et en
même temps en tant que dirigeant
d'entreprise
en effet il ya toujours à être vigilants
à voilà quelle place je donne au travail
dans ma vie et comment je me ressource
aussi pour est toujours en mesure de man
de gérer ou en entreprise une baisse de
juste équilibre et un travail sur ce qui
est à rechercher en permanence parfait
merci beaucoup d'avoir participé à cet
échange je précise quand même qu'il ya
71 % des français qui ont une bonne
image de l'entreprise et de sa propre
entreprise donc voila tout n'est pas
perdu comme lui disais tout à l'heure
merci encore à vous tous deux rappellent
donc ce petit livre que vous avez fait
paraître à compte d'auteur qui s'appelle
rebondir lumière sur mon burnout édité à
compte d'auteur un je crois c'est ça
merci bonne fin de vacances à tous
dimanche en politique que revient bien
entendu dimanche prochain et dans un
instant le point sur l'information comme
tous les dimanches excellent dimanche à
vous de ça
[Musique]